se cierra una ventana de esperanza para
los cientos de personas migrantes
bloqueadas a las puertas de europa
presas de las tensiones diplomáticas
entre minsk y bruselas cuyo destino es
de momento incierto
forster la idea de que puede haber un
corredor humanitario hacia alemania para
2000 migrantes como dijimos la semana
pasada y como dijo el ministro de
interior seehofer la visita a su
homólogo polaco no es una solución
aceptable para alemania ni para la unión
europea el presidente bielorruso aseguró
disponer un segundo vuelo de
repatriación hacia los países de origen
para las personas desplazadas en su
territorio
intentaremos hacer todo lo posible para
cumplir con lo que los migrantes quieran
si quieren regresar a irak o siria hemos
organizado un vuelo especial y
preparamos otro para final de mes si
tenemos suficiente gente aunque no
tienen muchas ganas de regresar a sus
casas
la unión europea oficialmente no
reconoce a lukashenko como presidente de
belarús pero es innegable su autoridad
de facto en el territorio de hecho el
bloque comunitario lo acusa de alentar
la ruta migratoria hacia las fronteras
exteriores de europa como polonia una
situación que el primer ministro polaco
volvió a calificar de guerra híbrida y
simbólica mientras visitaba la zona
fronteriza
haré lo que sea para nuestros ciudadanos
y para ustedes en europa para llamar la
atención de nuestros aliados
trasatlánticos y de europa occidental
sobre el peligro que afrontamos para
evitar lo peor
así quedaron temporalmente suspendidas
las diferencias en materia de derechos
humanos que venían enfrentando a
bruselas y varsovia encontraron la
comunión en el férreo control fronterizo
que define la política migratoria del
bloque europeo